طالب اللجوء الكردي صباح حسن من بين الذين
يواجهون امكانيه الترحيل الى رواندا بعد
انقضت المحكمه العليا في لندن بقانونيه
ابعاد مهاجرين دخلوا بريطانيا بطرق غير
نظاميه الى العاصمه الروانديه كالي والنظر
في ملفات لجوءهم هناك اللاجئون والمنظمات
المعنيه بشئونهم عبروا عن قالقهم الشديد
ايذاء هذا القرار
بصراحه هذا قرار سيء جدا
ستكون امنه او غيره امنه هذه المجموعه
الكرديه من طالب اللجوء اتت لتستفسر من
احد اعضاء الجمعيه الكرديه لندن بشان
تداعيات تاييد المحكمه العليا لتسويه
طلبات الراغبين باللجوء على بعد الاف
الاميال من بريطانيا
لحقوق الانسان يمكنها وقف الترحيل الى
رواندا وهناك عقيل اخرى قبل ذلك فالمصار
القضائي ليس نهائيا القرار
الخطه المثيره للانتقادات بابعاد الاجئين
وصلوا بريطانيا بطرق غير نظاميه الى
رواندا تبنتها حكومه جونسون باتفاقيه مع
نظيرتها في كيغالي لوقف رحلات عبور البحر
الخطيره لالاف المهاجرين من فرنسا الى
الجزيره البريطانيه ترحيل اول دفعه من
ثمانيه لاجئين الغيت الصيف الماضي بعد
تدخل المحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق الانسان لكن
وزيره الداخليه
في اقرب وقت ممكن
تبيعات هذا القرار غير الانساني وفور وصول
اللاجئين لايائهم قد ينقلون الى بلد لا
نعرفها
كسب وزاره الداخليه تاييد المحكمه لنقل
اللاجئين الى افريقيا للبث في طلباتهم
يضعوا على طريق تنفيذ خطتها التي لا تزال
حبر على ورق وكلفت دفع الضرائب حتى الان
120 مليون جنيه وقد تتطلب عده اشهر
لتنفيذها بعد انتهاء المسار القضائي مصطفى
زارو العربيه لندن